-[Uncle “Traveling" Matt] Gobo.
-[Gobo] Huh?
I want to show you something.
Behold!
Kinda looks like a hole, but...
I'm gonna assume it's more than that
based on the way you set it up.
♪♪
Woof!
Wow!
♪♪
Hold on to your Baloobiuses,
because I know exactly
where we should go.
Tell us in song?
I thought you'd never ask!
♪ Hey, okay ♪
♪ It's a party down in Fraggle Rock ♪
♪ Today, okay ♪
♪ And everyone's invited to the ♪
♪ Most perfect kind of day ♪
♪ At least since yesterday ♪
♪ Hey, okay ♪
♪ It's a party down
in Fraggle Rock today ♪
♪ Let's party down today ♪
I did it. I caught a Fraggle!
Doesn't it make you wonder
what else is out there?
What else is connected?
♪ Hey, okay ♪
♪ It's a party down
in Fraggle Rock today ♪
-Oh, wow.
-Ahhh!
♪ Let's party down today ♪
Woo!
♪ Hey, okay ♪
♪ It's a party down
in Fraggle Rock today ♪
Gosh, that is catchy.